bene tutti ragazzi per questo nuovo
video sono fa vj e commerce come l'altra
volta eravamo rimasti in the forest che
avevo tagliato di brutto il finale che
siete stati tutti contenti
sotto lato con il buon sasha ero in
trepidazione continuare a capire dove
arriveremo senza vivere senza la morte
perché non amo bravo una nave
grandissimo dammi il 5 la webcam surf e
questo è tutto tu lo vedi perché l'ho
preso preso come hai preso
e io lo vedo ancora la regione su due
perché sono condivisi e 6 rampini si
programmi i caxxi allora vediamo di
farci luce questo cosa volevo calciare
dobbiamo andare se mi ricordo
esattamente dove sono arrivato l'altra
volta è
quindi devo io non mi ricordo se ok
credo fosse ricorsa e non ne sono sicuro
però non ti serve al rampino adesso
perché il rampino ci fa tornare indietro
quindi dobbiamo tornare mi ricordo che
c'erano difetti dei bambini che volavano
quindi dobbiamo trovare i bambini e
bolano no aspetta sta partendo lavoro
scoperto merda dove cazzo siamo io c'ho
morta che schifo lima si risale in
superficie
tuttavia forse ho trovato di ho trovato
di pro io c'ho la xe visto una foto con
l'aics se sono due personaggi la bindi
alla bibbia la bibbia
oppure il libro delle challenge di
social face inizia a risalire qua sopra
allora non sono sceso qua e cioè non
sono salito qua controlliamo che cosa
sia prima di andare avanti perché non
era questa la strada della l'altra va
bene signor capitano però mai a vedere
che cazzo c'è quella nuova per curiosità
e per capire se usciamo da qualche altra
parte perché è possibile che siamo
veramente vicini all'uscita qui perché
si continuano a salire o di un amico
ceco ci sono di codice chignolo dobbiamo
far saltare in aria ma per farlo saltare
in aria
ecco caso faccio saltare in aria non c'è
la bomba fa niente tanto da qua cosi a
tornare
dobbiamo buttarci in teoria nella
voragine perché non mi ricordo più
dovere da dove ero sceso dall altra
parte sono un deficiente persona del
vice era dalla parte opposta
io ero stato apertamente in acqua pochi
a non cadere o ciò è ovvio che rumore di
acqua beh questa è mafalda saluta una
falda
oddio ho trovato un passeggero a è un
passeggero dell'aeroplano mi ha detto
found passengers e critico né è però non
ha una bella cera no mi sa che non usa
neanche il trucco esalta perfetto bravo
sembravano i platform aqua si può
scendere con la corda ecco e tutto
quanto la puoi saltare proprio dentro
dentro la conti fa niente però io direi
di tornarci un altro momento perché
siamo arrivati
allora zio qua in teoria c'è sia un kit
son dei feti ho già li vedo corrie non
guarda ma si sono suicidati del boss ma
quando corri se vedi un tizio tu corri
corri corri fottitene fatti tre
calcarono fottitene sai la corda
dove dieci fosse sta quasi forse sino ma
questo qua è caronte e quello che
traghetta le anime che non tessuto la
corda ma veramente con quanta ansia stai
salendo va bene anzi non ti ricordi dove
siamo ora eccolo perfetto santo iddio
provato ce l'abbiamo fatta
ragazzi miei è stato un parto se abbiamo
fatta ragazzi sono tornato col sesso
questa era allora questo era quello che
vedevo io quando tu tentavi di scendere
non riuscivi a scendere guarda ma perché
ci sono se si vede che dobbiamo andare
lì che c'è qualcosa in the hall messa di
domani poi ricordiamoci ti faccio vedere
un segreto
allora lei in teoria c'è una casetta
perché lo voleva io se era che l'ho
fatto che salviamo mica sono troppi
annunci sulle medicine aspetta guarda
qua dentro
non c'è niente
proseguiamo la stretta aspetta scelta
interiore persone di queste case la
facciamo
la boxe in l'unboxing vediamo se c'è la
leggendaria erano qua e non in questa
sodomia bravissimo bravissimo porca eva
bra visto sempre qualcosa come mary
poppins io prendo un pesce che cos'è
cosa attore ma è una borraccia allora
può essere usato per collezionare more
le more le bionde no di qua noi possiamo
scendere in teoria a piedi se io mette
un pezzo di clock a all'acs mi dice che
posso combinarle ecco lo porchera
bellissima guardaroba
la cosa che dicevo io e che secondo me
riusciamo a scendere pian piano da qua è
capito a ma tu annunciata per scenario
c'è una strada pian piano che guarda è
molto basso e vito per risalire nel
cannes
quello è un altro discorso e salva la
partita non salva altro salvato ci sei
sei pronto ragazzi vieni qua guarda ho
già trovato tutta la strada di nuova sì
sì no infatti come devo fare quest'anno
non avessi un piano perfetto cominetti
qua sotto mi sai crede secondo me sì
vediamo una licenza funzionalità ma se
non ci sono giochi 6 come sei tu a
esatto no la perfetta
mi sono scritto che intesa minchia qua
non so se scendere dalla barca tutta
quel casino dice ci sono due o tre piano
parlare perdiate piano poi fai piano
pianissimo porca [ __ ] ok non ti fai
danno se scendi qua
tieniti tutto dietro più dietro
possibile ci sei sono presente sotto
mato 95 ce l'ho io miur banale quanto
metà
ok prendi recupera tutta la vita chi
cazzo è quello c'è un boss
c'è il boss 90 è vero che c'era il boss
numero due sì c'è il boss numero 02
deciso di riscattare di qua e seguirlo
sì sì sì sì non si proceda strada
bravissimo perfetto ragazzi c'è il boss
numero 2 novak è bello per stasera un
arena lo vedi il vostro numero due
chi cazzo è quello laggiù c'è un boss
gigante e scriverci sono due rose nuovi
due cene sono nuovi questo qua che non
c'era prima
e ce n'è un altro ancora laggiù dove
dicono rosso avere un bosco su chris
info su coloro sono spettacolo c'è il
boss grosso più grosso vieni che
riusciamo a perfetto vedo che ci
sembrano l'elefante
ma chi è caduto natascha come c'era un
buco è serio ma 26 ma se sotto sotto la
voragine fugato zio sono sotto di me
europa non mi possono attaccare ab e
meno male non ho capito dove si è sceso
fammi vedere un dvd che sotto di loro si
vedo che si sottolinea non capisco mese
è sceso e c'era un bene avere lo vedono
veloce dell'acqua bene disse c'è un
punto dove ha più avanti c'è dell'acqua
la vedi sinistra sinistra e sinistra tuo
gringoire dritto dritto ancora sinistra
sinistra zio cio paura per sé una coppa
no è no no ci sono le pietre non tira
vai vai tranquillo ma dovrà esserci un
buco dove sono entrato ti dico solo che
il vostro si è fermato quindi ti segue
solo quello piccolo grande grande si è
entrato è ancora avanti perfetto di sono
non so come ho fatto ma sono riuscito a
caso no aspettava di arrivare anch'io
perché quel punto è strategico
bellissimo arrivo arrivo anch'io arrivo
e sei tu devi fare tutta l'acqua l'acqua
l'acqua a venire sul quale c'è un
buchettino tra due rocce
ok entra dentro ok e poi ti fa sbucare
di poco ok niente
ok come fatto a salire perfetto così una
valenza quanto è figo sucate vi le volte
che a chi è figata
è proprio matri ma solo due boss là in
fondo due l'acqua viva madonna sono in
due ma tutto ciò prossimo ma come faccia
no no è ascolto che ci sarà se casa dove
fottutamente è guardato su una porta
cazzo come porto era morto dove si
scende in sé è dietro del boss occhio
soprattutto la vedi che c'è una porta lì
si devono sacrificare io non c'è un modo
per costruire un arco narcos in teoria
lo puoi fare largo proveremo qualcosa
sta facendo quello che ha calciato una
pietra fortissimo e se le spara con la
pistola il flare non l'io non in fuoco
assolutamente sì però c'è il flash alla
royal vera ma prima devo dire fare ma
ama qua sotto di ci spara spara spara
spara
eccolo mancato e malmenati merda sasha
dai riprovi parali sparagli spara li
preparano ti perdono si perda c'è stata
è nota come sta salendo
noi e ai prof a [ __ ] difficilissimo
finché sarebbe fighissimo fatto sono
scemo per oggi loro era tentato di
colpire ma non mi colpisce di cornoltis
e cadendo e secondo bossi questo è o no
no no non ce la faccio più non ci
facciamo un giro ritirino li pianino li
provando a vedere cosa c'è nella porta
tanto ti faccio fuori io si traducono in
ottimi di tizio momenti di così si muove
citando il bosco dove sta più cagando mi
venga a darci una mano
non è vero che mischia il cavallo devi
morire se ti dona accetta in faccia ea
volto sta cercando cercando di ragionare
o una pentola che gli possono essere in
testa ho mangiato gli eventi in faccia
porca [ __ ] e morte morto ce l'ho fatta
tienilo li tirino fermo per qualche mio
fermo ok per quella strada libera ci ho
messo un'ora ma ce l'ho fatta
ok perfetto familiari questa porta
si è aperta sasha ragazzi miei
concludiamo qui anche oggi episodio di
the forest e sono team boss c'è ormai
inizia insomma stiamo procedendo per vie
malsane che spero che non ci potranno il
pazzo mi piaci vabbè non prossimi
episodi ragazzi di provincia piaciuto
questo momento non mi piace anche a me
come vietata la notizia né se dovessi si
scateni ci picchiavano prossimo visto
che oggi ha due telecomandi